I'm representative of real algebraic
geometry in this workshop and I was
asked to talk about the problems and
ways that we - breakin geometry can
contribute to hyperbolic programming and
hyperbolic polynomials and I've picked
two aspects the first part will mostly
be about ways to test if a given
polynomial is hyperbolic or not which is
related to the second part of
determinants or representations and in
particular I'll talk about the health
arena cough theorem that she'll already
mentioned yesterday and the generalized
legs conjecture and these types of
problems so as a warm-up so to speak
let's review some of the words that I
will use we've seen stable polynomials
as a related notion which is for me in
this talk luckily the same but it looks
different
so the half-plane property means if you
plug in complex numbers into your given
polynomial that have positive real part
you'll always get a nonzero number so
there are no roots of in the left half
of the complex plane and stable was you
have the same essentially but you say
positive imaginary part right so they
look almost the same but you fix
different planes half planes in the
complex plane where you require the same
property and I will be interested in
homogeneous polynomials throughout
almost exclusively and then these two
things are the same because you can pull
out an i or a minus I out of your
polynomial and just switch real and
imaginary part of your argument by
these two properties for me I luckily
the site and both of them in this case
of course then are related to
hypervelocity as Michele defined
yesterday so hyperbolic means for me
always that the poem is homogeneous so I
made it part of the definition and there
is a direction ie that is special for
this polynomial for now it has to be
nonzero at this point and when you
restrict to lines through any point in
this fixed direction II you get a
polynomial in one variable that only has
real roots now I will hopefully always
use the sign convention but I you know
reflection on the line you can also
change this to plus te and the condition
stays the same that just we parameterize
the line and because it's homogeneous
sometimes some people write also the
variable in front of the X instead of
the e
that's a projective transformation of
the line that also preserves the
property that you only have real roots
so this is what you do is you write e to
the D you pull it out and then you here
I have 1 over T that doesn't change real
rootedness because it's a productive
trend
and a little sneaky you know also
nothing but it reduces the number of
variables I have to check on the next
slides by one you have a hyperbolic
polynomial and you want to check
definition says plug in any X but of
course you're interested in all of the
lines in Direction e so you shouldn't
take any X but you can restrict to a
compliment of the subspace spanned by e
for example the orthogonal complement
because that gives you already all of
the lines it's sort of an affine
transformation of the line this will
reduce the number of variables for our
tests by one it's a very simple
observation that is in science talk no
let's see oh yeah we didn't do this
exercise yet I believe and it's
something you should do at some point a
real homogeneous polynomial is stable if
and only if it's hyperbolic in every
direction in the positive orphans that
result was mentioned I think at least
twice already this week it's a
relatively simple exercise that
somewhere on this long sheet I will
comment on the lengths of the sheets
okay we saw this result you two petaa in
Cheyenne's talk that characterizes
stable polynomials in the case that the
polynomial is multi affine so the degree
of this polynomial in every variable is
at most one there are no quadratic x i
squared or X I cute or anything like
that
and then the theorem says that the
polynomial is stable now the polynomial
is not homogeneous so I don't use
hyperbolic but I use stable if and only
if these weird polynomials are
non-negative for all choices of I and J
there's my notation for the partial
derivative of the polynomial with
respect to the I variable and so I would
like to take a moment to explain where
these polynomials come from they seem a
bit mysterious and that will prove one
of the essentially one of the directions
of the theorem which in my opinion is
the far easier one and the other one
point and the key word I think that you
can I think there's a debate about the
name but I've seen many people call
these things I'm going to talk about
wronskian even though the name is taken
in differential equations theory and is
a different thing so it's not the matrix
that you may know from differential
equations but it is this expression
given any two univariate polynomials F
and G so now I'm only talking about the
line I will form this polynomial so by
the chain rule that's polynomial by the
quotient rule and I claim that if these
polynomials have distinct roots and the
roots are interlacing with the
definition that we had if you look at
the roots along the line they alternate
first you have a root of say F then a
root of G then a root of F then root of
G and so on they satisfy this property
this polynomial will be a non negative
or if you change finds a non positive
function but it will not change sign
and then I made an exercise that's not
too hard to see but you require some
arguing the roots of polynomials and so
on and it's very much related to the
barrier function in nikhil stock so this
proves convexity of this function and
these polynomials that show up so let's
do this computation i claim i exactly of
this type so you argue that this is no
negative just along the lines using this
lemma and so let's do the computation so
what you should look at well we want to
produce the polynomial Delta I P Delta J
minus e times
and so I'm going to restrict a
polynomial
well it F why not name be I want to take
the I've derivative of P restricted to
the line X minus T Direction EJ so EJ is
the Jade standard basis vectors
I've lied maybe that's to this and G is
the derivative of it
take the I've derivative of P and you
plug in X minus T so these are two
polynomials along this line in this
variable and I claim the interlace by
vollis theorem the reroute of polynomial
this is a directional derivative because
it's stable so this e I is the high
isn't a hypervelocity calm if you take a
derivative with respect to a direction
in the hypervelocity cone you will get
an interlacing polynomial these
derivative relaxations and jim raynor
gets paper so if you have I have a poly
polynomial that looks like this
I draw an affine section of the cone the
hypervelocity cone right there is an
origin out here and you cone over this
that's the actual cone picture and if
you take a directional derivative
interlacing polynomial which will look
something like this
yeah and so this is why these two
univariate polynomials have interlacing
roots and now this if you apply this
front skein thing to these two
polynomials you get exactly this
expression because if you take a
derivative with respect to T you get the
directional derivative with respect to a
standard basis vector which is the
partial derivative with respect to X
step so if you apply this front skin
idea these two you get exactly this
which is why they are non-negative
what happens in our magical woods I mean
you have to worry a little bit but
that's essentially where these
polynomials
but it's it's an honest Ron scan right
it's the determinant of F F prime G G
prime that's what your prospect yes
although Transkei may have not intuitive
yeah
so this thing essentially proves one
direction of the theorem if the
polynomial is stable its hyperbolic with
respect to the positive orphaned so
these polynomials over there are
interlacing and then you use the
univariate case to show that they are
non-negative polymer the other direction
that 2 implies 1 and this for it since
you can use as a stability test you can
go ahead take your multi FN polynomial
you compute them all and try to prove
that these are non-negative polynomials
and this was explicitly done in a
particularly interesting example that
will show up later if you take the basis
generating polynomial the vamos mate
roid you can use this theorem to prove
that it's a stable polynomial we all
remember what the base is generating
polynomial is
[Applause]
Ramos Metroid is some matron of rank for
on eight elements sometimes I think it's
called be eight so the eight elements
so take to draw so what I'm trying to
draw it's not a 3q but I want to draw
the two faces that form about around the
three key so you leave off two opposite
faces say this one and this one so you
get specify the Metroid we have to pick
four elements subsets out of these
eights we pick all of them except for
these four faces and we pick one face
diagonal one this one so we don't pick
the four elements subsets corresponding
to this belt of two faces and one of the
diagonal elements these are the five
ones I do not pick and I pick all of the
other four elements subsets that
describes the vamos Metroid and then
these are the bases and the base is
generating polynomial is the sum over
all bases of this may trade multi linear
polynomial where you take the product I
be sorry that's the polynomial of degree
four and eight variables then it's state
so here that you need to check with the
renew area not just putting on girls you
have to check all of these somehow yes
but generally for general Cooper
Felicity also reduced to checking with
the polynomial
there's no negative one but actually
positive you need to check whether there
are no no we'll get to more refined yeah
I mean checking conditions in this case
can be reduced to stability and
stability you given so this I assume
here problem easily you given eat what
are you looking also for you know I'm
given in yeah so problem given II you
want to check with a polynomial is
parabolic in direction that's easy right
no it's not this hard because this
happened equivalent to slip the checking
step stability and stability is
essentially checking with the polynomial
has really lose no it's easier than the
number of variables is fixed
but Jake in one particular direction you
for all X on that because I have a
family of lies and so in their paper
they actually show that all of these
polynomials are non-negative they wrote
down at sums of squares proof of this so
but there might be but in others that
are negative but not do not omit the
same obscure certificate so it's not
known where the most ability would I
mean that the polynomials that arise
from a stable or the Euro would have a
sum of scroll certificate not always
that will also come to more details but
we cannot because it's a it's a it's
proven that it's a problem so in some
cases so checking stability is known to
become hard by can't be car yeah yeah I
don't it's actually reduced to that to
the checking the drill the
non-negativity of polymers it's not
clear to me but I think we'll get more
details and the first person might know
the stability no I did not do that the
Cardinals no harness kind of stability I
don't remember I can give you it's not
me so I what I did what I shown that you
can go from curb elicited the totals to
stability school from the is reduction
okay and I asked you on the exercises to
do some of these examples so to attempt
to check to use this theorem to check
with more mate roids if the bass is
generating polynomials are stable or not
and you can so if you want to do these
exercises this is a useful theorem to
remember
another thing that's quite natural we
already discussed right and the
definition if you go back to the
definition of being hyperbolic you ask
that all of the roots of a univariate
polynomial are real
it's a parametric family of those but so
essentially you want maybe to know how
do I count real roots of a polynomial
and we have seen some of the aspects of
this problem in Young's talk already and
I will review some of these things and
I've put here two references where you
can find more information that one of
the classical papers is by keine Naimark
originally in russian the english
translation has this long title and you
can find it online and there's a book by
pursue pollock and work called
algorithms in realized by geometry they
present all of these results also and
they do complexity analyses of these
algorithms if you are interested in that
sort of aspect but the problem is very
simple you're given a polynomial in one
variable T usually we assume that the
leading coefficient is 1 so that it's
actually degree D and then we want to
count and there are several algorithms
we've seen the hermit matrix before and
I will briefly review what this is but
there are other things you can attempt
to do there are student sequences an
algorithm you produce from this
polynomial a sequence of polynomials by
essentially doing the Euclidean
algorithm respect to P and its
derivative and then you have to plug in
points and look at sign changes roughly
how strong sequences work Aleutians is
also a technique that's very related to
the hermit matrix here also you produce
some matrix out of the polynomial and
you have to check signatures and
definiteness properties of this major
but I want to explain the hermit matrix
that we already saw and we saw many of
these other things appear so for now
suppose I know the roots suppose it
really has degree D and I have the D
complex roots in the plane I compute the
moments I call these power sons usually
in which so you take you fix the power
and then you sum over all of the powers
of the roots and then you build a matrix
which has huncle form by writing these
moments move along the top row and then
the last column and then you fill in the
huncle structure and you have
Sumeet matrix so for me as an algebra is
try it if you don't really care about
what the expressions are it's kind of
there's a simple argument for why these
moments must be expressible in terms of
the coefficients of the polynomial
because this is it's invariant under
permutation so it must be expressible in
the elementary symmetric polynomials
which are exactly the coefficients but
then you would like to maybe do that
also you would like to compute what
these expressions are and there's these
recurrences that enable you to compute
them that we've seen before
they're called Newton identities and
here I've assumed ad to be one otherwise
I have to divide
and so for instance were Kubik already
this looks kind of complicated so you
start essentially without the degree
here and one coefficient all right and
so these so let's see so the IJ entry
has degree I plus J minus two as a
polynomial in the coefficients so this
is the three three entry as degree four
of the polynomial but you can write them
down only in the coefficient so you
don't actually need to know the roots of
course which would be sad if we needed
to know the roots to count those
all right also another aspect that's
kind of annoying about these matrices if
you have a polynomial that is real
rooted entries become quite big quite
fast thing that happens okay but you can
compute them in the theorem says again
is an exercise that you can count the
number of distinct complex roots by
looking at the rank of this matrix so in
this example that's a rank 3 matrix
because we have three distinct complex
roots and the signature will tell you
how many of these roots are really the
signature of this matrix which is the
number of positive eigenvalues minus the
number of negative eigenvalues of the
matrix times the number of distinct real
roots if you have a multiple root it's
only counted once
happier so this is supposed to be one so
because of the hunk of structure right
so these entries ought to be the same
and this entry is this one and then
these are really just the recursions
from the new tonight
so let's try to use this to count real
roots along lines tests hypervelocity of
a given polynomial so suppose PE has
degree D and I want to test with respect
to a specific given direction so I'm
given E and I want to know if it's
hyperbolic with respect to me if you
also want to search for the direction
okay so what you're going to do is you
want to test these univariate
polynomials so you expand as a
polynomial in T because the polynomial
was homogeneous these coefficients will
be polynomial ax polynomials in X that
are homogeneous of sort of the right
code degree so this is homogeneous of
degree D minus 3 of the monomial in
particular this year is the constant
this is just the value of P at E this
here is a homogeneous polynomial of
degree D so now you've done that you use
these recurrences to plug them into the
Hemet matrix they are only in terms of
the coefficient which are now
polynomials in X the min so let's try
this for this cubic polynomial in three
variables so that is hyperbolic with
respect to this point I've rigged the
example you expand yeah I only plug in
X's now that's the trick I used that are
in epub I choose a complement of the
direction to reduce the number of
parameters I want to get rid of this X 0
which is unnecessary it's really a
problem to that so I plug in 0 x1 x2 and
then this is my direction I expand as a
polynomial in T and now I plug these
coefficients into the recurrences of the
slide before this 3 this here is minus
this coefficient this is the polynomial
in this and this and so on
so you get this matrix and you would
like to know if this matrix is positive
semi-definite for every value of x1 and
x2
talk to test
but it's a possible way to test type of
publicity in a given direction so here's
the theorem that's really just applying
the Hameed sylvester theorem to these
parametric Hameed me
so how do you test such a thing so one
thing you can attempt to do is to use
sums of square certificates for
non-negativity and it's the following
observation so this H of P is a
symmetric matrix whose entries are
polynomials you can still make a
quadratic form out of it in more
variables so I introduce new variables
y1 up to Y equal to the size of the
matrix which is 2 D minus 2 right it's
bounded by the degree polynomial P and
then I make this quadratic form out of
it - but the coefficients of this
quadratic form in the Y's are
polynomials in the XS but the matrix a
is positive semi-definite for every X if
and only if this quadratic form is a
non-negative polynomial in the XS and
the Y's and that now you can attempt now
we have a polynomial right you can
attempt to do this using semi definite
programming for example write down the
sums of squares proof
sometimes this will work in the
following sense so if the matrix
polynomial here is in one variable or
homogeneous in two as in our case of the
slide before it's homogeneous in two and
you can get rid of one of them so if
this is in one variable then every
non-negative symmetric matrix polynomial
is a sum of squares there exists such a
certificate so there no negativity of
this matrix doesn't tell you how hard it
is to find but at least it exists so in
this sense for turns out if you do the
details that for homogeneous polynomials
in three variables that's an exact
method that reduces to the problem of
finding the sums of squares certificates
more variables than three this is a
relaxation approach as usual you can
guarantee even if it is non negative
that you will find such
so this has essentially been done
explicitly and more cleverly in a paper
by Ragavendra rider and NICU it's
essentially this method I've just
discussed for homogeneous polynomials in
three variables or stable polynomials in
two phrases so there is an algorithm
that checks whether our parametric
Hameed matrix is positive semi-definite
for every axis in running time that's
polynomial in the degree and I want to
sort of roughly describe what the things
are that make this so what the clever
aspect are how do you check this they
don't use sums of squares because we
don't know the complexity of some of
those pairs of SDP feasibility problems
so you have to do something else so
let's try to see roughly what you can
attempt to do in this case divorce
complexity yeah I mean yeah when you
fire in relation because here's the
number of variables
he's right record saying yeah yeah yeah
but so it was one with D to the power of
5 so this is pointless
I haven't checked do you know what
so we're trying to check so first of all
this is phrase for stable polynomials
right so I want to get back to my
hammock matrix so you have to carefully
homogenize and this was done that one is
a careful analysis of how you have to
modernize such a thing which was two
polynomial which is now not homogeneous
but in two variables stable
if and only if the following polynomial
is hyperbolic in some direction so you
homogenize the thing eh um is now
polynomial in three variables and you
get it by of the degrees D in X / Z Y
divided by Z it's two very polynomial
and then you clear denominators genius
polynomial in X Y Z so if this
homogeneous thing is hyperbolic in
directions to all
are too you can ply though you only to
III e1 and e2 can be true dimension or
positive or things where you have the
last coordinate equal to zero so that is
how you prove that that's not very hard
to see you have to sort of carefully or
modernize and check
so but now you have to sort of test
hypervelocity of this polynomial with
respect to this family of directions
even so that's step 2
let's try to check same this implies
that P is stable if an only if now come
the conditions we want to check two
things are satisfied condition one one
parameter family of things no meals few
gamma of T to get by plugging in gamma
plus T comma T comma zero no in this
thing into the five area original
polynomial if this is really rooted in T
and secondly need to check that the high
publicity cone is big enough so you have
to check that the homogenization
along sort of spanning line segments is
a compact base of this cone is poverty
see between open right
so this is essentially checking that
it's hyperbolic with respect to all of
these directions because I've taken
I know that it's hyperbolic in one
special direction and I know that it
doesn't have any zeros along this line
segment I know that the hyperbole
aesthetic cone because it's convex and
the cone contains the positive or really
checking for zeros along this line
segment checks that the hyperbola city
cone is what it ought to be and this is
sort of the parametric who meet me
all right now you have to do this so
what do you do you compute the Hermit
matrices and the moment formulas went
away these coefficients of this
polynomial in T here are now polynomial
expressions in gamma you know the
degrees by this recurrence formulas you
can bound the degrees of the entries of
this parametric omit matrix so if you
compute the characteristic polynomial of
this parametric matrix you can bound the
degrees of the code so the coefficients
of the characteristic polynomial will
also be polynomials in this parameter
and you can bound the degree by staring
at this carefully enough so what they
attempt to do is compute the
characteristic polynomial directly by
interpolation because they have bound so
you compute these hermit matrices you
evaluate them at roots of unity because
that works well and then you compute the
determinant then you have values of the
characteristic polynomial and then you
interpolate to determine these
polynomial coefficients okay so that's a
lot of work and standard technique I
think so what what have you gained once
you have the coefficient of the
characteristic polynomial you can check
if the matrix is PSD by checking that
the coefficients are non-negative
polynomial so you produce a bunch of
univariate polynomials and you have to
check that all of them are PSD
essentially one way you can attempt to
do
and I think you get a worse bound for
this right so you have to be even more
careful you want D to the five you don't
compute these
and then you have to be even more clever
and not compute the whole characteristic
polynomial butts up resultant or
something little bit better but you have
to be even more so for these small
number variables you can do this and in
general attempt to do all right
of course I haven't told you how you
check non-negativity or a univariate
polynomial even if you want to do this
algorithmically you have to be yes
another thing you can maybe attempt to
exploit is what the set of all
hyperbolic polynomials looks like in
this vector space [ __ ] polynomials we
have fixed the number variables we look
at homogeneous polynomials of some
degree and we have a fixed direction
then there is a set of hyperbolic
polynomials and the geometry of the set
or the topology I should say what
studied never pronounce this name does
anyone know that
there are various some people call this
now others knew each other so he wrote
the note and hyperbolic polynomials back
in the sixties maybe even and to
understand what the theorem says we need
sort of one more property a polynomial
is even better than hyperbolic it's
strictly hyperbolic if it does not have
multiple roots along any of these lines
so whenever you restrict to these lines
you get a univariate polynomial none of
them have any multiple roots it is
equivalent to a geometric property if
you draw the hypersurface if you draw
the zero sets it's equivalent to the
fact that the zero sets does not have
any real singularities you only have a
multiple root if for example some of
these connected components come together
and along this line
have a multiple root and that's
essentially the only way this connect
them are to proof so strictly hyperbolic
is equivalent to the fact that the real
zero sets is smooth the gradient is non
zero at every real zero of the pony
anything special so in order to status
correctly as a technical detail you have
to normalize everything so I'm only
looking at hyperbolic polynomials that
evaluate to 1 at the fixed point
otherwise some of the statements do not
mean what they should and then now I
have two sets I have those polynomials
that are hyperbolic in this direction
and I have the subset of those that are
strictly hyperbolic and then the
following things are true the set of all
strictly hyperbolic polynomials is an
open subset you believe this
characterization that kind of plausible
right having a singularity is a closed
property if you don't have one and you
wiggle the coefficients roots very
continuously it should stay it should
stay simple along these lines so that's
essentially the reason behind this
statement and you can approximate every
hyperbolic polynomial by strictly
hyperbolic polynomials is exactly the
closure in the Euclidean topology of the
strictly hyperbolic ones and the
interesting part that may be useful is
that this is actually contractable all
moto P equivalent to a point so there is
a you can connect every hyperbolic
polynomial by a path to a strictly
hyperbolic polynomial and the path so
the work simultaneously for all of them
use the same path and you see it on the
next slide to connect any hyperbolic
polynomial to some mysterious strictly
hyperbolic polynomial and this
mysterious path looks kind of ugly and
this is the definition I'll walk you
through in a second but it really is a
very very simple idea and the very
simple idea is again you should look at
univariate the univariate case what
happens along one line and then
generalize this correctly to
multivariate case and the univariate
lemma is one of the exercises with one
exercise 9 it's a very simple
observation you have a univariate
polynomial ax is real rooted
and let's see plus s times P prime is
reroute
essentially this as the chosen here and
you reduce the multiplicity of a route
if you do s times P has simple roots
everywhere
every roots
it's not a root of he
and the multiplicity of course of a root
of P they has a multiple root of
multiplicity goes down if you do this to
the nested and that's really what is
behind these mysterious things on this
slide you know how to do it on one line
you need to think carefully of how you
do this sort of for all lines
simultaneously and the trick is that you
look at these weird operators which take
partial derivatives with respect to G so
I've made some simplifying assumptions
so my direction is the first coordinate
vector and I call the first variable
something special maybe t and all of the
others exits this is if you want more
generally this is the directional
derivative in the hypervelocity
direction now normalized to be the
partial derivative of spectacle
and then you have this perturbing
parameter s that's the s from the
exercise and then you have to make this
homogeneous again because we want to
talk about hyperbolic polynomial so you
have to pick some linear form to fix the
degree of this thing and which linear
form you pick is up to you and sort of
these operators that show up here tell
you well why not take all of the
variables this is sort of to take care
of the fact that you need to check this
along all of the lines so if one of the
X I were equal to zero in your line then
maybe this thing would not exactly
correspond to our univariate lemma so
you sort of do it just to be safe in all
directions or in all of the directions
of a basis essentially what smooth is
out into a strictly hyperbolic
polynomial but we want to connect to a
fixed one right we want this to be a
contraction and that's why you do this
weird GS you rescale the X's because for
s equals zero this is always the same
polynomial no matter what P words it's a
hypervelocity it's the cheapest ever so
for s equals zero
no matter what P was this is always T to
the degree and then you can sort of
apply all of these things you get
something but that does not depend on
the actual P anymore that's sort of the
point that all of these paths connect to
f1 apply to t to the D that's the
mysterious strictly hyperbolic
polynomial but sits inside where all of
these paths come in and these are paths
as a function of parameter I move from 1
to s is 1 then I don't do anything
because I don't rescale here and you
have done 1 minus so s is 0 so I don't
do anything with these maps equals 1 I
just get my feedback this is a very
explicit path you started s equals 1 or
0 yes
exactly
so these things look kind of complicated
if you want to know what happens to
exercise 9 and then you've understood
the essential part the argument the rest
is worrying about parametric families of
life
so of course
now clear how to really use this one
thing you can attempt to do try to
determine as a now you fix your
polynomial P now you have this path as a
Karimun is a univariate thing as a
function of s so you can try to detect
if somehow along this way
the polynomial is not strictly
hyperbolic anymore there's the boundary
of hyperbolic polynomials by the theorem
on the slide before it's really
determined by those that have a real
singularity this a little bit you can
make it non hyperbolic but in order to
be able to do this the strictly
hyperbolic polynomials are open you need
a singularity if you perturb a strictly
hyperbolic one then it will remain a
hyperbolic polynomial with respect to
your fixed direction so you can attempt
some things like this which I think
computationally are very non promising
because these discriminants are
notoriously very difficult
oh yeah that's
so that's the path that proves the
theorem
so instead of doing these discriminant
things a natural thing you can try from
an algebra point of view which
complexity wise is also I think maybe
not the best approach but you can at
least do some small examples small
degrees quite explicitly is to look at a
resultant type of thing so what the
resultant the resultant takes two
polynomials as input and it produces the
polynomial in the coefficients that is
zero if and only if they have a common
root so you can try to use this on a
real and imaginary part of your
polynomial in the following sense so
suppose you have P hyperbolic with
respect to the first standard basis
vector so you want to test in fact if
all of these univariate polynomials as a
parametric family in X is really rooted
so instead of doing this maybe you plug
in sort of a general complex number so
now T 1 and T 2 are constrained to be
real numbers
before here T is a complex you know I'm
talking a complex number here now I want
to plug it in like this with its fixed
real part which is now a real variable
and its imaginary part which is now a
real variable ok and you multiply this
out you get some things that have an I
in front some that don't and this you
call the real part of this polynomial
imaginary part and now the question is
do they have a common root there were
polynomials hyperbolic in this direction
if and only if they have no common root
where the imaginary part is nonzero
I want this to be real rooted so I want
the imaginary parts of every root to be
zero and how I phrased this in a sort of
contra positive resultant type way now I
want to do if these polynomials have no
common real roots by the imaginary part
of my complex number is not unless you
can check sultans or more generally
right so now you want to check if some
two polynomials in fact have no common
real roots and there is a tool to do
that it's called the reason which turns
apps which gives you a certificate of
infeasibility for this type of systems
of polynomial equations so what it says
is if you're given real polynomials do
not have a common root which is exactly
what we want then there exists a
certificate of this type so there exist
polynomials any polynomials Q 1 up to Q
K and the sum of squares of polynomials
such that this holds why is this the
reasonable certificate of infeasibility
if you plugged in a common real root
this term would go away right because
all of the fj's would be 0 it's a common
real root on the right you have minus 1
and on the left you have a sum of
squares evaluated at a real point it
gives you a non-negative number that's a
contradiction so this is really a
certificate if you can write this down
there's an immediate proof that there is
no common root
by plugging it in now of course we have
this constraint that s2 is nonzero and
in not equal constraint which you can
get rid of with a standard trick so you
introduce non a one new variable for
these non equal constraints and you
apply the regional transit to the
polynomial real part imaginary part and
then you enforce the condition that t2
is nonzero by having that this
polynomial is equal to one new variable
and then I just wrote down really this
certificate for these three polynomials
inequality this inequality constraint
gives you here a new variable and a new
equation
all right any questions so far yes is
there like any natural and that look of
that streak your prop elicited for
stability
I'm just curious my goodness
there are no roots were all real parts
are non-negative and at least one is
positive so it is like yours but it's
equivalent to this one it is actually
cool it s s staple I think several
different ways but it's a Cleveland OH
but this is equivalent to what they say
put sale in the in the real let's say
real homogeneous case and there are no
roots were the real personal negative
and at least one of them is positive so
the standard stability the nerve roots
will fall is it the same because from
death and also this wasn't every used
this ninja result or for some proofs it
wasn't well it's just stands on its own
it is convenient that you can assume
strictly hyperbolic that I mean this
part for example is used
you can approximate every hyperbolic
poem by a strictly hyperbolic one I
don't know if this path has been no no
no for that for that approximation based
very strictly
and I'm sure off the top of my head
some of these topological things it's a
convenient disclosure thing is a
convenient thing will health and vinegar
you could imagine youth their results
about these hyperbolas recode though
strictly hyperbolic polynomials like
being whatever projections of yeah you
could imagine using this to very well
approximate its approximation thing it's
used yeah that for sure but the path
explicitly I'm not sure if ever once K
because the Anala called instability
that streets the build is actually makes
certain induction easier I just don't
know an example but it has probably been
used to restrict a publicity makes this
question of finding a sniper he drove
Saturday there's a non constructive
all right so this is sort of the
hypervelocity testing part so I think
it's time for some exercises as you may
have noticed the exercise sheet is very
long so pick some problems to work on
for now
some of them have shown up in earlier
talks some of them are more
computational some of them are more
theoretical some of them you can
actually really solve if you don't know
the things and haven't been to my second
talk yet so look at some of the problems
after the second talk and what I would
like to try today what I would like you
to do is to take the time sort of until
the second talk the coffee break and the
exercise part to work on these problems
optimally you would get together with
someone you don't know yet especially
from a different department the Holden
SES Department all math people look
carefully matthew who's in the math
department OCS people look carefully and
try to maybe find someone to work on
these problems with and then if you are
interested in solutions first of all
I'll be around you can ask me questions
and for the in the lunch break I'll grab
a sandwich or something and I'll be
upstairs on the second floor and so we
can then to ask questions or talk about
something everyone who wants to do such
a thing we can meet sort of for lunch on
the second floor
discuss all of you question solutions
problems approaches and so on but for
now I would like you to use the time to
actually do as many of them as you feel
like then I guess we'll be here again at
some point 11:15
[Applause]